the frozen continent of Antarctica may
be far from the world's population
centers but what happens in the rest of
the world is having a big impact there a
CBS News team recently traveled to the
region with researchers and
environmentalists and as Roxana Saberi
reports they say more must be done to
protect the area and fast as one of the
most remote regions of the world
Antarctica shines with natural beauty
but on our trip there scientists working
with environmental activists from
Greenpeace told us this beauty is
fragile and it's at risk of fading fast
change is the thing that's difficult
here and what we're seeing is rapid
change
Alex Borowitz tracks penguins by
counting them one by one you joined him
and his team from Stony Brook and
northeastern universities on the rocky
cliffs of Elephant Island these penguins
don't seem bothered by us they're
natural predators come from the air in
the sea but scientists say with
temperature's rising faster here than
most of the rest of the world man-made
climate change is a threat to their
survival these researchers have found
that the islands population of chinstrap
penguins named for the black line
beneath their beaks has plummeted by
more than 60 percent since the last big
survey 50 years ago chinstrap numbers
have dropped across the region as
temperatures have soared by more than
five degrees over five decades so when
we see climate change impacting things
down here glacial melt warming oceans
penguins do really interact with with
all of those things one theory is that
shrinking ice is also shrinking the
chinstrap supply of food
Shemp like creatures called krill but
there are also fewer krill to go around
because there are now more whales that
feed on them that's a rare bit of good
news for biologists Kirsten Thompson
well so far we've been seeing quite a
lot of humpback whales which is really
exciting
that's great I mean this population is
one of the populations that's been
increasing in recent years
thanks to no whaling in this area but
Thompson is also studying a new threat
one that's little-understood a form of
pollution called microfibers they're
pieces of plastic coming from synthetic
fabrics we wash frankly so small you
can't see them with the naked eye
Thompson and Greenpeace are testing the
sea water for microfibers at the same
sites they did two years ago back then
they found tiny plastic particles in
almost all of the samples do you know
what the effects are we know that
they're found in the guts of fish and we
know that in some cases that microfibers
microplastics can accumulate up the food
chain all the way to us human beings
possibly just one reason Greenpeace says
we need to protect places like this the
activists are pushing for a UN treaty
they say could lead to the creation of
sanctuaries protecting 30% of the
world's oceans by 2030 pressure on the
oceans is very very high and we need to
turn that around because in the end the
oceans are our best allies against
climate change and we need healthy
oceans for the future this pressure they
say is man-made
and it's up to us to do something before
it's too late for CBS this morning
Saturday Roxana Saberi Elephant Island
Antarctica penguins were having fun
there for how long is the question we
got to know at 70% of the population
from one of the glass pieces she did
wiped out interesting very interesting
piece it's a great report environment so
we need to start taking care of our home
yeah although we won't be around for
another 250,000 years